getting ready for another day at the
market in Athens but for fishmonger
Yanez cats Adela's business is slow it's
now five years since the Greek economy
collapsed many people can only afford
the basics people just want to survive
and feed themselves how can you live on
a pension of three hundred and fifty
euros I get a paltry pension things
could soon get worse analysts say the
Greek government has nearly run out of
money to pay salaries and pensions one
option under discussion is to introduce
iou's essentially a kind of voucher one
man who thinks that's a good idea is
German economist Thomas Maya he's long
been calling on the Greek government to
introduce iou's the so-called euros
would act as a kind of parallel currency
Josh turns easy for each pin on say I'm
a civil servant who normally earns a
thousand euros a month do you the
government can only afford to pay me
seven hundred fifty euros food to go but
saw so they give me two hundred fifty
euros as an IOU join what we need coffee
if I don't have enough savings to live
on I then hand over the vouchers to
someone else serving to collapse a
currency right there are you to gaben
I'm human done knows hundred homes in
the video but the model requires traders
to accept the vouchers without knowing
when or even if they'll eventually be
exchanged for euros as a result the giro
would be worth less than the euro and
circulate faster to the DS available you
still see God for consumers this
currency would be like a hot potato
everyone would be trying to pass it on
nobody would want to just hold on to it
because they have little confidence and
it's worse Bob so they'd swap it for
goods which gets things moving against
women unya not everyone shares Myers
enthusiasm Stavros could see Bella's
from Greece's civil servants Union does
not think I owe us are the way forward
hey must be something we oppose such
measure and will not accept it as a
framework for discussions mr. we're
calling for a systematic restoration of
our salaries not a further reduction
which would in effect amount to a pay
cut yeah better tell me asusta much so
how would an alternative cheaper
currency affect Greek business could it
be an opportunity for employers to cut
salary costs we head to a brewery in
northern Athens to find out it's German
educated boss says pay isn't the issue
for him the problem is the high interest
rates being charged by the banks and he
says introducing another currency
wouldn't help us bring garnet it
wouldn't do any good after all we have
loans in Euros Enzo fam hi this velvet
so I don't think it's a good idea we
should really put the discussion to one
side now there are lots of people
throwing ideas out there who really
don't know anything about the Greek
economy they take a bird's eye view of
everything nothing more than a fanciful
model then not so says economist Thomas
Meyer he maintains a parallel currency
would buy Greece much needed time and
would be preferable to a grexit scenario
assistance often kinda insolence it's
not a case of delaying insolvency
because one could use the time gained to
introduce economic reforms and to lay
the foundations for more gross what will
happen if the country runs out of euros
many Greeks are tired of speculating
okay how should I know we have to live
with whatever the politicians decide
after years of hardship there's still no
end in sight to Greece's economic woes